Hello, and welcome to the last video in this course.
For this, we're just going to be going over some final points to sort of round out your
understanding of the engine and to give you a good idea of what your next steps or what
you would like to learn about next is to fit your personal workflow.
So for this, I'd like to start with coding.
Unreal Engine works with a number of different languages when it comes to coding, but the
main two are C++ and our visual scripting language, Blueprints.
Unreal Engine is built in C++.
It is a very fast and powerful programming language, and it allows you to organize your
code into a reusable component, which is excellent for optimizing things like game performance.
Underneath Unreal is built in this language, but it is not a necessity to learn this in
order to use Unreal Engine.
That's where Blueprints goes in, so we're going to talk about.
As we mentioned, when creating a project, you can select it to be an either Blueprints
or C++.
It doesn't matter terribly, but if you're in C++, you are going to have to work with
an IE, such as Visual Studio.
So C++, very powerful, compiles down to be very fast, but it is a complicated programming
language and there is a bit of a barrier to entry that you have to learn how to program.
It also isn't directly in the editor, which means once you compile something, you're
still going to have to go back into the editor in order to implement its usage.
Blueprints are our visual scripting language.
This was added to the engine quite a while ago.
When it was clear on computer games, you tend to have a lot of creative, non-coding people,
stuff like level designers and artists, that you would still like to expose some of the
power of the code to.
It is in a visual plug and play setup, allowing you to place nodes down, and it is much quicker
to learn and to get up and rolling.
As far as powerful, it does actually compile down to be C++, so when a program is packaged,
it can be pretty much as fast and it's often not the coding which will be your bottleneck.
But the other excellent thing about this is because it's in editor, it's very quick to
make code changes and see them reflected within the editor sort of immediately, which is great
for an artist's workflow, even though it might not be as fast as C++.
It is fast enough that many, many computer games have been released almost entirely in
Blueprints, so it is powerful enough for you to release something as a program.
Just going to show this in the engine quickly.
As you can see here, I've got a third person character.
If I drag this into the world, it looks like this.
If I was to also open this up, who would open up and it would show us the Blueprint coding
language here.
So we can see that it has a number of functions such as being able to jump when a specific
key is being pushed.
And so this is where we would find it in something that's called an actor or a Blueprint.
Of course, but we can also find that we have an equivalent in the level Blueprint.
So this would allow us to code stuff into a specific level.
Or we could find them all across the engine.
Most of the elements of the engine have Blueprints attached to them.
And this is why it is something that's really important to learn.
Even if you are not a coder, it is worth knowing the basics of Blueprints because it really
can be a force multiplier on whatever your workflow it is from animation to rendering
to materials.
Blueprints touch almost every part of the engine.
Even though it is a coding language, I do recommend you learn a little bit of it.
It's easier than you'd imagine.
And it is incredibly powerful no matter what your role is.
Next up, we have Sequencer.
Now Sequencer allows us to use a timeline to control what's going on within the engine.
Now this is most commonly used for things such as cinematics or rendering out animations.
But it can be used for a lot of different things within the engine.
And it's whenever you want something to be controlled over a timeline.
As a quick demonstration of how Sequencer would work, there is a flapper board icon
pop on the toolbar here.
I always press that and select Add a Level Sequence.
It's going to ask me to save something.
But after I do that, it will bring up a Sequence panel like this.
Now if there was to find a Skeletal Mesh, I'm just going to search for Skeletal Mesh.
And I'm going to bring him the Manny and rotate him to place the camera.
I was to go back to my Sequence and add him, selection from Content Browser.
You can see that we would get something that's called the Control Rig Rotom.
This is something that needs to be set up.
But it allows me to do stuff such as very simple animations.
And I can get a lot better.
And see if I start with the arm in the air here.
Can I just key that?
And then I will key it again over here.
And in the middle, I'll move his arm to the other side and key that.
And now you can see we've got a very simple straightforward animation.
I'm just doing that quickly to sort of demonstrate what it does.
You can also add cameras in and then you can use the Movie Rendering Queue to render stuff out.
And the system gets incredibly complicated with different shots and stuff like that.
So it's very powerful.
But this just gives you an idea of if you are looking to generate animations,
you really want to learn about Sequencer.
And that's where you're going to get that from.
Finally, I'd like to talk about Materials.
So Unreal runs with a PBR workbook,
which means we do something that's called physical-based rendering.
You try and discern how light would interact with the surface
so that we can create something as realistic as possible.
Now, we create Materials.
And this is very similar to how it is done in a lot of other programs.
As you can see here, I have filtered the Content Browser by Materials.
If I just drag them in, lay some on here,
you can see that we get a very different effect
dependent on what material is added to our mesh.
Now, if I was to open up one of these Materials,
this would show us an example of a Material Graph.
But the main thing to know about a Material Graph is we have the Output here,
where what is plugged in to any of these settings
is going to determine how it looks.
So for example, we have the Base Color is going to determine the color.
Roughness is going to determine how much light is diffused off of a surface.
So lower a Roughness, the more reflective it is,
emissive will make it grow.
Normal is going to fake geometry to add sort of shadow
and elements to something where we don't have the geometry.
And there are a number of other ones here.
We are able to change the Material domain,
Blend Options and a whole load of other different elements.
But in this case, we are plugging textures
into the Output, which would then be stretched across the Material
based on how we use it in the coordinates.
And this same workflow can be used for post-process Materials,
for magic effects, numerous different elements.
But again, if you're a technical artist or working Materials,
this would be where you'd go to put together your Materials.
And with that, we have come to the end of our course.
Hopefully that has given you a good foundation
and allowed you to know what sort of things
you would like to go into more depth into.
Thank you very much.